how did you process the fact that hey i
could be the guy that this team is going
to bank on to turn the franchise's
fortunes around uh i mean as a kid
that's what you dream of you know going
to an
organization and being that guy
you know turning the program around
organization around and you know winning
super bowls and you know like i said i
don't shy away from hard work i feel
like
i'm not here to lose games or
go through the motions i'm here to
change change things up so uh
i'm ready to go and i can't wait
that's kyla murray number one overall
pick in the draft and we hope he is
great i am a huge kyler murray fan he
was phenomenal at oklahoma even as he
was shredding my west virginia
mountaineers on the friday after
thanksgiving but he is special and i
like the fact that that he is the next
in this line of short quarterbacks that
can quite possibly get it done at the
nfl level chris but the biggest change
obviously for the cardinals a team that
was the worst in the nfl last year from
a standing standpoint earned the first
overall pick in the draft what do we
think big picture of what they've done
to try to turn the page on last year's
disaster yeah i mean big picture i think
it's been a pretty good offseason by
steve kym and company i really do i mean
when you look at free agency you go okay
they they addressed a lot of different
positions middle linebacker getting you
know jordan hicks marcus gilbert a
tackle adding some depth to the
secondary with guys like tremaine brock
you know adding depth on o-line with j.r
sweezie you get some veteran leadership
like a terrell suggs in the building
right also take a chance on a kevin
white who used to be a top 10 pick uh
wide receiver who went to west virginia
you know all about him and when he was
at west virginia cliff kingsbury was at
texas tech watching him playing against
him so there's some improvements there
on free agency with darius philon as
well to help the defensive line and then
mike i thought really the draft was
phenomenal by the arizona cardinals not
only kyla murray won uh but the corner
byron murphy at the top of the second
round one of the best nickel corners in
the draft this year getting really wes
welker slash julian edelman 2.0 and andy
isabella in the end of round two i think
is going to be huge for this team
getting a hiking butler a giant wide
receiver 50 50 type ball guy zach allen
they had a good draft is what i'm trying
to say i just thought it was a really
good offseason by steve kime they needed
it because there's so many positions on
that team that needed to be filled or at
least needed to have better depth or
better quality depth altogether
i think what happens when a team makes
some big high-profile moves that draw a
lot of attention scrutiny criticism etc
from hiring cliff kingsbury as the
surprise head coach of the team to
making kyle murray the first overall
pick to trading josh rose in the 10th
pick from last year a lot of the other
moves don't get
noticed they don't get paid much
attention to and i think quietly the
cardinals rebuilding this roster the way
that they want to the way that they
think they need to as they try to
compete in a division that
has got to be the toughest for a fourth
place team to navigate right now because
the 49ers stay healthy they're going to
be good the seahawks are the seahawks
the rams are the rams and the cardinals
need to be something other than what the
cardinals have been the past few years
and you know it begins with cliff
kingsbury and kyler murray but all these
other guys that get less notice they're
going to have a huge say in whether and
to what extent this team can be
successful yeah no definitely i mean hey
set you know the second round pick from
last year to texas a m christian kirk
it's gonna be some of those guys buddha
baker from you know two drafts ago or
three drafts to go from washington they
need some of these young guys that
they've drafted to kind of assert
themselves on their football team but
the biggest reason and when you really
sit back and like i knew we were going
to talk about this last night you pull
up their roster you look at things they
do you know one of the big things i go
man it was a good thing they got kylo
murray with the number one pick there's
just not a lot of difference makers on
their roster all together and i think
really at the end of the day that's why
they had to get a kyler murray not only
for the sexiness of the football team so
the fan base and you know the media and
all of us will talk about them certainly
that was great but they don't have guys
or a lot of guys that can take over
games or take over certain situations on
offense hey larry fitzgerald he's
getting up there in age we know that has
come to an end a good football player
but he's not taking over anymore they
got david johnson but damn it's hard to
take over a game at running back
uh and running the football when there's
nothing to scare a team from throwing
the football so kyle murray will help
really uh you know accentuate david
johnson's skills and on the defensive
side of the ball same thing chandler
jones patrick peterson yeah they're
there but we know corners you can avoid
them if you don't want to attack them
and they don't have a lot of difference
makers in that front seven either and
that's where again i go back to like a
guy like hassan riddick who they picked
in the top ten a few years ago in the
draft they got to start coming up the
pipeline and showing that they were
worthy picks by steve kyme and they're
going to contribute to this football
team
you mentioned david johnson if this team
is going to be competitive he needs to
get back to the form that we last saw in
2016. he had over 2 000 yards from
scrimmage remember he's the guy that
they settled for when they wanted a
mirror abdullah they were the subjects
of the very first all-or-nothing series
on amazon they wanted amir abdullah in
the draft they didn't get him they got
david johnson he was great his first two
years wrist injury week one of 2017 gone
for the year last year got the big
contract right before the season began
he still had 940 rushing yards and 446
receiving but not the kind of year that
that he has expected he wants a thousand
and a thousand rushing and receiving and
if he does that if if we are talking
after week 17 that hey david johnson
pulled it off a thousand rushing and a
thousand receiving that will mean the
cardinals were special in 2019 and
johnson has shown he's got that kind of
special skill that would allow him to do
that yeah no he does mike i mean he is
like he's levy on bell right i mean he's
that type of football player he can do
both he's special i think that's really
you're hitting on one of the big
question marks or at least one of the
things i want to see take place during
this year cliff kingsbury from that air
raid offense right mike leach throw the
ball every down that that's not going to
work in the nfl you're not going to be
able to throw the ball 50 times a game
and think you're going to win on a
weekly basis sorry you're going to have
to run it and that's something i really
want to see from cliff kingsbury what
what kind of run schemes is going to
bring to the table what's his patience
like gonna be with the running game
what's his patience gonna be there
because he comes from a school of oh
just keep throwing it keep throwing it
and we'll throw some wide receiver
screens to act like the run game and you
don't wanna get david johnson out of
this offense you want to make him the
focal point to what you're saying
and you know it it just feels like a
bunch of different pieces that need to
fall together just the right way and
it's on kingsbury to make it all come
together and make it work offensively
and defensively if it does it's not
going to be easy they can be relevant in
a very tough nfc west
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports